[Música]
en France 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy Valentina
Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos en esta ocasión vamos a
iniciar en Barcelona por a conocer
algunas iniciativas presentadas en el
Mobile World Congress la mayor feria
tecnológica de Europa y en esta ocasión
fue presentado un interesante artefacto
médico que podría ayudar a miles de
personas en el mundo veamos el informe
de lisgasengel y moduatin
así que lleva 24 años en una silla de
ruedas pero hoy camina entre los Stand
de la feria mundial de los móviles
Muchas gracias destinado a un uso
hospital agrio este exoesqueleto le
permite dar pequeños pasos más que
necesarios a nivel terapéutico estar de
pie es súper importante para nosotros a
nivel de riego sanguíneo osteoporosis
por ejemplo intestinos
vejiga para meter infecciones Pero
además una cosa que parece muy
importante es el aspecto emocional a la
experiencia mejor es mirar a la gente o
estar a la altura del resto de las
personas una vez formados los médicos
pueden usar el dispositivo para
cualquier paciente en función de su
grado de parálisis
pues va conectado a una aplicación móvil
y desde la aplicación móvil podemos
personalizar todos los diferentes
parámetros los diferentes ajustes del
dispositivo a las necesidades de cada
paciente algunos asistentes se muestran
seducidos por este dispositivo más
ligero que otros modelos y con un precio
más asequible también ha comentado que
tienen el roadmap desde desarrollar una
versión doméstico que esto sería muy
importante para gente como nosotros
aparte de los smartphones y otros
gadgets para el entretenimiento este año
el Mobile Congress demostró que la
tecnología también puede ser útil este
robot quirúrgico
híbrido permite al cirujano o pegar en
modo manual o controlando los
instrumentos desde esta consola usando
gafas 3D para más precisión poder
combinar instrumentos robóticos y
instrumentos manuales Pues nos parece
que es una buena vía para facilitar la
usabilidad y al final mejorar la
eficiencia y la de robótica quirúrgica y
así poder universalizarla toque la
tecnología puede ayudar a las personas
estas empresas esperan poder volver en
2024 y tener cada vez más peso entre los
2000 expositores presentes en la feria
vamos ahora a hablar de globos
aerostáticos pero no para espiar sino
para proporcionar acceso a internet en
zonas remotas es el proyecto de la
compañía World Mobile y utiliza estos
globos con forma de dirigible llamados
Air notes los artefactos estarían atados
en una ubicación particular y pueden
brindar la misma cobertura que 12 Torres
de telecomunicaciones tradicionales
según la compañía
conectamos a los desconectados y a los
desatendidos hay alrededor de 2500
millones de personas en el planeta que
no están conectadas Y en este momento no
hay soluciones plausibles para
conectarlas usamos aerostatos y una red
terrestre para poder conectar a las
personas los responsables del proyecto
destacan la necesidad de un mundo Cada
vez más conectado y resaltan que África
es el continente con menor número y
calidad en la conexión por lo que
iniciaron esta iniciativa en la isla
tanzana de Sanz para probar el concepto
allí centraron sus operaciones durante
dos años para mejorar su producto y
ahora ya tienen planes en Nigeria Kenia
y mozambique y en otros países del mundo
los aerostatos los Globos como la gente
los llama tienen un buen Rango de
cobertura alrededor de 130 kilómetros a
la redonda cuando están ubicados a una
altitud de 300 a 500 metros lo que
realmente sabemos hacer es ser capaces
de adaptarnos a lo que se necesita sobre
el terreno muy rápidamente y
proporcionar una solución inmediata
los responsables aseguran que se
necesitará construir bueno sitios de
telecomunicaciones lo que a su vez
significará menos cables tendidos los
aerostatos justamente actúan como una
torre de Comunicaciones y los usuarios
pueden conectarse directamente usando su
teléfono inteligente como lo harían a
una torre tradicional
finalizamos con la tecnología de
clonación virtual Y eso es precisamente
lo que hace la empresa japonesa alt que
ofrece un Clon digital que tiene vida
eterna el proyecto se llama personal
artificial intelligence y crea un Clon
virtual para grabar la vida y
transmitirla a familiares o personas
interesadas
queremos recolectar tres tipos de
información de nuestros clientes con su
consentimiento claro la primera es la
voz la segunda fotos y videos cualquier
elemento visual y la tercera es la
información conversacional para clonar
como piensan
el principal uso es personal
porque el concepto de este producto es
la vida eterna
[Música]
así que puedes grabar tu vida en este
Clon y cuando mueras puedes dejarlo a
tus descendientes
así finalizamos este espacio a ustedes
Les agradecemos su sintonía y los
invitamos a continuar con nosotros en
France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]